From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
There have been seven Peaches in the duo Peaches and Herb over the years. But it was Peaches number three-- her real name's Linda Greene-- in the biggest hit ever, singing the duet with Herb.
多年来，“桃子与香草”二重唱组合中先后出现过七位“桃子”。但在这首史上最热门的歌曲中，与香草合唱的正是第三任“桃子”，她的真名是琳达·格林。
[MUSIC - PEACHES AND HERB, "REUNITED"]
[音乐 - 桃子与香草，《重聚》]
(SINGING) I was a fool to ever leave your side. Me minus you is such a lonely ride.
(演唱) 离开你身边是我太傻。没有你的我，旅途如此孤寂。
We live in a country where 3 million people have purchased copies of this song. And Peaches number three tells this story. She was on tour, and she visited this elementary school back in the day. And she has asked these little kids-- first, and second, and third graders-- what their favorite song was, and they all shouted, "Reunited." And what they said was, that song was played when my mommy and daddy got back together.
我们生活在一个有300万人购买过这首歌的国家。第三任“桃子”讲述了这个故事。当时她正在巡演，去了一所小学。她问那些小孩子——一、二、三年级的学生——他们最喜欢的歌是什么，他们全都喊道：“《重聚》”。他们说，这首歌是在我爸爸妈妈复合时播放的。
And you know what that speaks to? There are not many songs for people who split up and get back together again. The reunited couple is a completely under-served market, right? There's "Love Is More Comfortable the Second Time Around," there's "Break Up to Make Up," and there's "Reunited." That's pretty much it. Oh, wait a second, here's the chorus.
你知道这说明了什么吗？关于分手后又复合的人的歌曲并不多。重归于好的情侣是一个完全未被满足的市场，对吧？有《第二次爱的感觉更舒适》，有《分手为了和好》，还有《重聚》。基本上就这些了。哦，等等，副歌来了。
(SINGING) Reunited and it feels so good. Reunited 'cause we understood, there's one perfect fit--
(演唱) 重聚了，感觉真好。重聚了，因为我们理解，我们是天生一对——
Who is singing the songs for the reunited people? Who is writing their stories? Well, today on our radio show, we tried to redress this grievous, grievous oversight and tell three stories of reunions-- in each case, very unlikely reunions that were gotten to through very unusual means. Act One is a man reunited with a woman. Act Two is a man reunited with an animal. Act Three, a man reunited with a nation. Sarah Vowell tells that last story. And let's just get right to it, huh?
谁在为重归于好的情侣唱歌？谁在书写他们的故事？好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们试图弥补这一严重的疏忽，讲述三个重聚的故事——每一个都是非常不可能的重聚，通过非常不寻常的方式实现。第一幕是一位男士与一位女士重聚。第二幕是一位男士与一只动物重聚。第三幕是一位男士与一个国家重聚。莎拉·沃威尔讲述了最后一个故事。咱们直接开始吧，好吗？
Act One, "Not Your Parents' 'Parent Trap.'" This is a story of two marriages-- one unhappy, the other happy. One's an arranged marriage, the other's by their own choice. One's a big formal wedding, the other's in City Hall. One's in Iran, the other's in America. The only thing they have in common is the bride and groom, who also are the parents of Nazanin Rafsanjani, who tells our story.
第一幕，“不是你父母的‘天生一对’”。这是一个关于两段婚姻的故事——一段不幸，一段幸福。一段是包办婚姻，另一段是自由恋爱。一段是盛大的正式婚礼，另一段是在市政厅举行。一段发生在伊朗，另一段在美国。它们唯一的共同点就是新郎和新娘，也就是纳扎宁·拉夫桑贾尼的父母，她将为我们讲述这个故事。
From the day my parents met to the day they were married, it took three weeks, which wasn't so out of the ordinary in Iran in 1973. Back then, people didn't get to date. It just wasn't done. They had to leave it to their families to choose a spouse for them. They got married and hoped for the best.
从我父母见面到结婚，只用了三周时间，这在1973年的伊朗并不罕见。那时，人们不能自由恋爱。根本没有那种事。他们必须让家人为他们挑选配偶。他们结婚，然后祈祷一切顺利。
Now that I know how my parent's marriage began and ended, I can hear hints of how the next 30 years would go for them in the different ways they described their feelings at the very beginning. This is my mom, Mina.
现在我了解了父母婚姻的开始和结束，从他们描述最初感受的不同方式中，我可以察觉到未来30年他们生活走向的端倪。这是我的母亲，米娜。
I thought, he asked me, and he's serious. And I thought I'd fall in love with him. And I thought, well, I have to get married, and he was right there.
我想，他向我求婚了，而且他是认真的。我想我会爱上他的。我心想，好吧，我必须结婚，而他正好出现在那里。
[LAUGHS] So, wait. He was right there? Or you thought you-- or you were in love with him?
[笑] 等等。他正好在那儿？或者你以为你……或者你当时爱上他了？
He was right there. And I liked him a lot. And I thought then, I thought I liked him a lot. I loved him. I loved him, I guess, then. Yeah. I think. [LAUGHS] I was only 19, for god's sake. [LAUGHS]
他就在那儿。我很喜欢他。那时我想，我真的很喜欢他。我想我当时是爱他的。我想是的。 [笑] 我才19岁，老天。 [笑]
Were you in love with Mina?
你爱米娜吗？
Yeah.
爱。
How did you-- tell me how you felt.
你当时感觉如何？告诉我。
Well, love is love. I don't know how to explain about love. When you love somebody, so you want to do everything for her.
爱就是爱。我不知道怎么解释爱。当你爱一个人时，你会想为她做任何事。
This is my dad, Abbas. It was always less complicated for my dad. From the beginning, he loved my mom. And from the beginning, my mom didn't know what it meant to love him.
这是我的父亲，阿巴斯。对我父亲来说，事情总是没那么复杂。从一开始，他就爱着我母亲。而从一开始，我母亲就不知道爱他意味着什么。
My mom borrowed her wedding dress from a cousin. They were married in a large hall in downtown Tehran, with lots of food and dancing. It was all new and fun for my mom, until that night. There was this business of proving my mother's virginity, which meant my grandmother, my dad's mom, sat outside their room and waited for a piece of white cloth that would prove my mom was pure.
我母亲向表亲借了婚纱。他们在德黑兰市中心的一个大厅举行了婚礼，有大量的食物和舞蹈。这对母亲来说既新鲜又有趣，直到那天晚上。那是证明我母亲贞洁的仪式，这意味着我的祖母，也就是我父亲的母亲，坐在他们房间外，等待一块白布，以证明我母亲是纯洁的。
My grandmother carried it downstairs and displayed it for my dad's entire family, who were there waiting. For my mom, a 19-year-old girl who had never held hands with a boy before, this was traumatic, and she didn't want to talk about it on tape. This was the beginning of her marriage and her sex life.
祖母把它拿下去，展示给我父亲的所有家人看，他们都在那里等着。对于一个从未和男孩牵过手的19岁女孩来说，这是一种创伤，她不想在录音中谈论这件事。这就是她婚姻和性生活的开始。
My mom has a saying. I've heard it over and over growing up. An Iranian marriage is like going to the grocery store and buying a watermelon. You don't know what you've got, until it's too late. By the time my mom realized she wasn't happy with her watermelon, my parents were already parents.
我母亲有一句口头禅。我从小就听过很多遍。伊朗的婚姻就像去杂货店买西瓜。直到为时已晚，你才知道你买到了什么。当我母亲意识到她对自己的“西瓜”不满意时，我的父母已经有了孩子。
The main issue was my father's temper. He could erupt at any time. My mother tiptoed around it. She started to shut down. She expected my dad to throw a fit about everything.
主要问题是我父亲的脾气。他随时可能爆发。我母亲小心翼翼地应付。她开始封闭自己。她预料到父亲会对任何事情大发雷霆。
She has lots of stories, like the time she went to get her driver's license. In Tehran at that time, everybody failed the driver's test. So to practice, people took it several times.
她有很多故事，比如她去考驾照的那次。在当时的德黑兰，每个人都会挂科。所以为了练习，人们考了很多次。
One day, my dad decided my mom should get some practice, so he drove her to Tehran's DMV and sent her inside, expecting to wait 10 minutes. But miraculously, she passed and then was shuffled into another line to take the driving test, which she also passed. In the end, what should have been a 10-minute failure ended up taking two hours. Finally, my mom emerged ecstatic with her brand new license.
有一天，我父亲决定让母亲练习一下，于是他开车带她去德黑兰的车管所，让她进去，以为只用等10分钟。但奇迹般地，她通过了，然后被安排到另一条队去参加路考，她也通过了。最后，本该是10分钟的挂科，结果却花了两个小时。最后，母亲拿着崭新的驾照狂喜地走了出来。
So I just walked out and I showed him my-- you know? I passed, I passed! And he started to yell at me. I told you 10 minutes! Why are you so late? You're so stupid! I had a meeting. I thought, so if you had all those things, why did you want me to go and take the test?
我走出来向他展示我的……你知道吗？我通过了，我通过了！他开始对我大吼大叫。我告诉过你10分钟！为什么这么晚？你太笨了！我还有个会呢。我心想，既然你有那么多事，为什么还要让我去考试？
And then after that, it's like, I always remember he would calm down, and then he would just forget that it ever happened.
之后，我记得他总是会平静下来，然后就假装什么都没发生过。
Yeah, he just-- nothing happened. Every time that I wanted to bring it up and to tell him, you know, you embarrassed me and you embarrassed yourself. Did you realize there was 10 people were looking at you? Your kids were looking at you? He said, you're making too big of a deal. Nothing happened. Everybody gets angry.
是的，他就是……好像什么都没发生。每次我想提起这件事，告诉他，你知道，你让我和我自己都很尴尬。你意识到有10个人在看着你吗？你的孩子们在看着你吗？他说，你太小题大做了。什么都没发生。每个人都会生气。
It was kind of like living with an alcoholic.
这就像和一个酒鬼住在一起。
This is my sister, Nilofar.
这是我的妹妹，尼洛法。
Because you never knew. Like, one second we'd go out for a picnic, and it'd be sunny, and everything would be great. And literally, the camera wouldn't work. And he'd freak out, and the rest of the day would be shot to hell.
因为你永远不知道。比如，前一秒我们出去野餐，阳光明媚，一切都很美好。但实际上，相机没法用。他就会抓狂，剩下的一整天都彻底毁了。
When people asked me about my parents, I'd say, my mom doesn't love my dad, my dad loves my mom, and they're not very happy. And the only one who probably didn't see it that way was my dad. Nobody ever complained to him about his temper. And even now, he has a hard time remembering the moments that upset the rest of us.
当人们问起我的父母时，我会说，我妈不爱我爸，我爸爱我妈，他们过得不太开心。唯一可能不这么看的人就是我父亲。从来没有人向他抱怨过他的脾气。即使是现在，他也很难记起那些让我们其他人感到难过的时刻。
I thought it's OK. Yeah, I thought if asking somebody your life is OK, your marriage is OK, yeah, I said, it was OK. Because as a-- I don't know. Maybe as a Iranian man, I didn't see anything wrong.
我觉得还可以。是的，我想如果向某人求婚你的生活还可以，婚姻还可以，是的，我说，这还可以。因为作为一个……我不知道。也许作为一个伊朗男人，我没觉得有什么不对。
My dad wasn't just being clueless. By Iranian standards, there was nothing wrong with this marriage. Most of my mother's friends put up with a lot worse. And my mom was the first one to say that if they'd stayed in Iran, in an entire society that thought about marriage the way her Iranian friends did, my mother wouldn't have hit a breaking point.
我父亲并不只是迟钝。按照伊朗的标准，这段婚姻没什么不对劲。我母亲的大多数朋友忍受的情况还要糟糕得多。而我母亲是第一个说，如果他们留在伊朗，在一个看待婚姻方式与她那些伊朗朋友相同的社会里，她是不会达到崩溃点的。
It happened when she was 40 years old. And because of complications from a medical procedure long ago in Iran, she'd had to get an emergency hysterectomy.
这发生在她40岁的时候。由于很久以前在伊朗做过手术的并发症，她不得不进行紧急子宫切除术。
My sex desire just gone down to the drain. And I talked to him. I said just, I really can compromise with you. You're a healthy guy. You have highly sex drive. And I'll work with it, but you need to work with me, too.
我的性欲简直降到了谷底。我和他谈过。我说，我真的可以迁就你。你是个健康的男人。你有很强的性欲。我会配合，但你也需要配合我。
"Work with me" meant she'd still have sex with him, but a lot less than he wanted. He said, no.
“配合我”意味着她仍然会和他过性生活，但次数比他想要的少得多。他说，不。
And he said, you know what? I'm still young, and this is my desire. If you wanted me not to get angry, be happy, you know, be good husband, take it or leave it. And that night, I thought, OK, I'm all yours, [LAUGHS] until my kids get out of the house. Then, I did my plan.
他说，你知道吗？我还年轻，这是我的欲望。如果你不想让我生气，那就快乐点，你知道，做一个好妻子，要么接受，要么滚。那天晚上，我想，好吧，我属于你， [笑] 直到我的孩子们搬出去。然后，我制定了我的计划。
When they had this conversation, I was in eighth grade. And we'd been in the US for almost nine years. I never knew this was a turning point, but my mother tells me it was the moment she started plotting her divorce.
当他们进行这次谈话时，我还在上八年级。我们在美国待了近九年。我从不知道这是一个转折点，但我母亲告诉我，那一刻她开始策划离婚。
This was a huge step for her. My family has lived in Tehran since the 1880s, and in that time, no one, not one couple, has divorced. In 125 years, everyone on both sides of my parents' families has stayed married. And that's not because there were so many happy marriages.
这对她来说是巨大的一步。我的家族自19世纪80年代以来一直住在德黑兰，在那段时间里，没有一个人，没有一对夫妻离婚过。在125年里，我父母双方家族的每个人都维持着婚姻。这并不是因为有那么多幸福的婚姻。
My mom plotted the divorce for six years. She waited until I left home and went to college, before she told my dad she wanted out. He was shocked. He'd had no idea this was coming.
我母亲策划离婚策划了六年。她等到我离家上大学后，才告诉父亲她想退出。他很震惊。他根本不知道这事要来了。
And then, as if they wanted to make things as uncomfortable as possible, they continued to live together for six more months. My mom had no other place to go. She filed the official divorce papers without telling my father while they were living in the same house. It was a pretty grim time.
然后，就像他们想让事情尽可能不舒服一样，他们又在一起生活了六个月。我母亲没有别的地方可去。她在没有告诉父亲的情况下提交了正式的离婚文件，当时他们还住在同一个房子里。那是一段非常阴郁的时光。
I couldn't sleep. I couldn't eat. And from a very small period of time, I start to drinking. And I thought, OK, this is not good. And then, I went to see the doctor, and he put myself in medication, like a Prozac or something. And that one helped me a little bit. But still, I was very, very-- I thought this, my life is done.
我睡不着觉。我也吃不下饭。在很短的一段时间里，我开始喝酒。我想，好吧，这不好。然后，我去看医生，他给我开了药，比如百忧解之类的。那个稍微帮了我一点。但我仍然非常非常……我想，我的人生完了。
I was constantly worried about my father. I had no idea how he'd manage living by himself. I was still in college working as a secretary when I got a phone call one day. It was my dad sobbing. I had seen him cry once before when his father died. And that time, he cried quietly. And I could tell he didn't want me to be any part of it.
我一直担心我父亲。我不知道他一个人怎么生活。有一天，我还在上大学，做着秘书工作，接到了一个电话。是我父亲在抽泣。我以前只见过他哭过一次，在他父亲去世的时候。那次，他静静地哭了。我看得出来，他不想让我卷入其中。
On the phone that day at work, I had no idea what to do. I was in a crowded office, trying to sound like I was having a casual conversation. People kept walking by, and I was trying to make my voice sound calm. Other calls kept coming in, but I couldn't put my dad on hold when he kept repeating, I can't do this, over and over again. I felt the same way talking to him-- I can't do this.
那天在工作中接到那个电话，我不知道该怎么办。我在一个拥挤的办公室里，努力让声音听起来像是在进行随意的交谈。人们不停地走过，我试图让我的声音听起来平静。其他电话不断打进来，但当他反复说“我做不到”时，我不能让他等待。和他谈话时，我也觉得一样——我也做不到。
But for the first time in my life, I started spending time with him anyway, because I was scared for him. He'd come and visit me at school. I always made sure it was for breakfast. I remember thinking that nobody gets too hysterical over breakfast.
但这是我一生中第一次开始不管怎样都花时间陪他，因为我为他担心。他会来看我，去学校看我。我总是确保是在早餐时间。我记得我当时想，没人会在早餐时歇斯底里。
Do you remember talking to me about Mina and the stuff during that time?
你还记得在那段时间和我谈论米娜和那些事情吗？
Yeah, for the first year, I remember I talked to you about Mina. And then after one year, I tried to not talk about anything at all, because I beg her, I ask her, OK, back together. But when she said, no, I said, OK, this is never happen. It's going to be never happen. Why should I bother her? And somehow, I want to, a little bit, forget about Mina.
记得，第一年，我记得我向你谈论过米娜。后来一年后，我尽量不去谈任何事情，因为我恳求她，我问她，好吧，复合吧。但当她说不时，我说，好吧，这永远不会发生了。这永远不会发生了。我为什么要打扰她？不知怎的，我想，稍微忘掉米娜一点。
While I was worried about my dad, I was excited for my mother. For 27 years, she thought my dad was the one thing holding her back. And my sister and I thought what she thought. We had this glorious, liberated woman vision for her.
当我在为父亲担心时，我也为母亲感到兴奋。27年来，她一直认为父亲是阻碍她前进的唯一因素。我和我妹妹也和她想的一样。我们对她有一个辉煌、解放的女性愿景。
I pictured her coming home, relaxing with a glass of wine. I pictured her dating, throwing her head back in laughter at sophisticated jokes told by handsome men her age. I thought she'd divorce and turn into a completely different person-- a much happier person. For a very short time, I was right.
我想象着她回家，喝着红酒放松。我想象着她去约会，听着英俊的同龄男人讲着复杂的笑话而开怀大笑。我以为她离婚后会变成一个完全不同的人——一个更快乐的人。有很短的一段时间，我猜对了。
There was a lot of relief. Looked like somebody took a big, heavy weight off my shoulders. So I don't have to call person every two hours and tell him where am I. I don't have to cook all the time. I don't have to clean all the time. So it was me, and me, and me.
感到如释重负。看起来有人从我肩上卸下了一个沉重的负担。所以我不需要每隔两小时就打给那个人告诉他在哪儿。我不需要一直做饭。我不需要一直打扫。所以就是我，我，还有我。
So went to, you know, coffee shop, and sit there and read the newspaper. It was such a good feeling. I never had it, because I went from my parents' house to my husband's house.
所以我去了咖啡馆，坐在那儿读报纸。感觉真好。我以前从来没有过这种感觉，因为我从父母家搬到了丈夫家。
She read the newspaper at a coffee shop exactly three times. She never dated-- not once. And things started getting harder.
她在咖啡馆读了三次报纸。她再也没有约会过——一次都没有。事情开始变得艰难起来。
My mom called me all the time in tears. She'd talk about how much she hated my dad. And she'd tell me how lonely she was. She had all of this energy, and nobody to direct it to now that my dad was gone. My mom had always seemed so independent, but that was when she was surrounded by people who depended on her.
我母亲一直含着泪给我打电话。她会说她有多恨我父亲。她会告诉我她有多孤独。她有这么多精力，但现在父亲走了，没有地方发泄了。我母亲一直看起来那么独立，但那是当她被依赖她的人包围的时候。
I was so isolated. My family weren't around. My kids were so busy. And my friends were very kind, very nice, but after in two years divorce, I never, ever had experienced that they invited me with the bunch of friends. They invited me like I'm a drug dealer, and nobody have to see me. And they feed me one night, and kick me out of the door.
我太孤立了。我的家人不在身边。我的孩子们太忙了。我的朋友们很友善，很好，但在离婚两年后，我从来没有经历过他们邀请我和一群朋友聚会。他们邀请我的时候就像我是个毒贩，没人想看到我。他们请我吃顿饭，然后把我踢出门外。
Meanwhile, my dad was reluctantly turning into an American bachelor. He joined a gym. He had no food in his refrigerator. He was always at work at his dry cleaning business. And if he did have any free time, he spent it reading that most American of genres.
与此同时，我父亲正不情愿地变成一个美国单身汉。他去健身房。他的冰箱里没有食物。他一直在干洗店工作。如果他真的有空闲时间，他会花时间去读那种最典型的美国类型书籍。
Actually, I read a lot of book about relationship between man and woman. And one is give me good information-- Men are From Mars, Women are From Venus. I want to give myself more knowledge, what I did wrong. If I want to go to have a relationship with other lady, I don't have to do something like that.
实际上，我读了很多关于男人和女人之间关系的书。其中一本给了我很好的信息——《男人来自火星，女人来自金星》。我想让自己获得更多知识，看看我做错了什么。如果我想和其他女士建立关系，我不能再做那种事了。
I can't believe I'm saying this, but Men are From Mars, Women are From Venus changed my father's life. It's hard to imagine my dad sitting in his little apartment struggling with chapter titles like, "Women are Like Waves," and "Healing the Resentment Flu," but I can see why this book helped him. There's a thing in the beginning about how many marriages this book has saved and how everyone at any age is capable of change. And that's exactly what my dad needed-- someone to give him a chance.
我简直不敢相信我在说这话，但《男人来自火星，女人来自金星》改变了我父亲的生活。很难想象我父亲坐在他的小公寓里，费力地读着像“女人像波浪”、“治愈怨恨的流感”这样的章节标题，但我明白为什么这本书对他有帮助。书开头提到这本书挽救了多少婚姻，以及任何年龄的人都有能力改变。而这正是父亲所需要的——有人给他一个机会。
The book offered simple advice like, as a man learns to listen and interpret a woman's feelings, communication becomes easier. If he becomes very frustrated while listening, he should not try to continue. Instead, the respectful thing to say is, I really want to hear what you are saying, but right now, it is very difficult for me to listen. In this passage, the word "listen" appears eight times. For my dad, who'd never been exposed to the idea that wives needed to be listened to, this was revolutionary.
书里提供了简单的建议，比如，当男人学会倾听和解读女人的感受时，沟通就会变得更容易。如果他在倾听时感到非常沮丧，他不应该试图继续。相反，尊重的方式是说：我真的很想听你在说什么，但现在，我很难听进去。在这段话中，“倾听”这个词出现了八次。对于我父亲这种从来没接触过“妻子需要被倾听”这个想法的人来说，这是革命性的。
You know, I thought I'm right, that because I'm right, now everybody is not--
你知道，我以为我是对的，因为我是对的，现在每个人都不……
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Yeah, because of that. And some chapter of this book is give me, so OK, no, you wasn't right. You have to relax and then listen.
是的，因为那个。这本书的一些章节让我意识到，好吧，不，你不对。你得放松，然后倾听。
My dad started dating. But the book didn't teach him not to talk about his ex-wife on his dates, so nothing was working out. But he was determined not to be alone. So he had relatives in Iran introduce him to a woman, and he got engaged.
我父亲开始约会。但这本书没教他不要在约会时谈论前妻，所以什么都不顺利。但他决心不再一个人生活。于是他让伊朗的亲戚介绍了一位女士，他订婚了。
By this time, about 2 and 1/2 years after their divorce, I was more concerned about my mother than my father. It was my father who, of the two of them, was seeming more liberated. My mother just seemed stuck. Every time I went to her house, there were three maps of San Jose covering her kitchen table. She'd get home from work and just sit and stare at them, tracing out new and better routes she could take to her office.
到这个时候，在他们离婚两年半后，比起父亲，我更担心我母亲。他们两人中，看起来更解放的人是我父亲。我母亲只是显得停滞不前。每次我去她家，她的餐桌上都铺着三张圣何塞的地图。她下班回家，就坐在那儿盯着它们，描绘出她去办公室的更好、更新的路线。
All of her willpower had been used up just getting herself free. I remember being so disappointed in my mom. She'd come this far, and then sort of just stopped. There was nothing left in her to find someone new.
她所有的意志力都耗费在让自己获得自由上了。我记得对母亲感到非常失望。她走了这么远，然后就停下了。她身上再也没有动力去寻找新人了。
In one point, I was in an airplane one day, and I saw a couple of old couples. And I thought, oh, my god, I wish I was them. I wish I had my, like, 30-years husband beside me.
有一次，我在飞机上，我看到了一对老夫妇。我想，哦，天哪，我希望我是他们。我希望我有像我那陪伴了30年的丈夫在我身边。
And I was sitting behind them, and she started to explain to the guy that this is her friends, and this is that, and this is-- I thought oh, they're dating. They're not husband and wife. I thought, I don't want to-- in age 50, I don't want to explain to somebody my every single detail of my life. I want somebody to know me.
我坐在他们后面，她开始向那个人解释这是她的朋友，那是那个……我想，哦，他们在约会。他们不是夫妻。我想，我不想——在50岁的时候，我不想向某人解释我生活中的每一个细节。我想要一个了解我的人。
And yes, he gets angry. Yes, he's short-tempered. Yes, he's that, but I got old with him.
是的，他会生气。是的，他脾气暴躁。是的，他是那样，但我和他一起变老了。
Not long after that came the day my mom did the second most surprising thing she would ever do in her life. It was two days after her 49th birthday. She called my sister to get together and celebrate, but my sister was busy.
没过多久，我母亲就做了她一生中最令人惊讶的第二件事。那是她49岁生日后的两天。她打电话给我妹妹想聚在一起庆祝，但我妹妹很忙。
She said, no, we celebrated your birthday year-- I mean, a week after we were going somewhere. And why don't you get a boyfriend? Nah, dah, dah, dah, dah. [LAUGHS] She said, if you're lonely, you have to get a boyfriend, and your problem is going to be solved. You know, we have a life. And that day I thought, this is not working. I need to fix this.
她说，不，我们庆祝了你的生日……我是说，一周后我们要去别的地方。你为什么不找个男朋友？[笑] 她说，如果你寂寞，就得找个男朋友，你的问题就解决了。你知道，我们有自己的生活。那天我想，这样不行。我得解决这个问题。
This is not working. I have to leave these kids alone. I have to get somewhere that I don't need her that much. I thought, let me try that old man again. [LAUGHS]
这样不行。我得让孩子们独自生活。我得去一个我不需要那么依赖她的地方。我想，让我再试试那个老头子吧。[笑]
One day, I remember Sunday afternoon, telephone is ringing. And I pick up the phone. After, I think, one year, it is Mina.
有一天，我记得是星期天下午，电话响了。我接了电话。我想，一年后，是米娜。
I called him, and he got so surprised. He says, what's going on? Are you OK? I said, yeah, I'm OK. I was wondering, when is your wedding day? He said, well, two months from now. And you know, it's just I'm flying two weeks from now. I said, well, congratulations.
我打给他，他很惊讶。他说，怎么了？你还好吗？我说，是啊，我很好。我想知道，你的结婚日是什么时候？他说，好吧，两个月后。你知道，我两周后就要飞过去了。我说，好吧，恭喜你。
I told you, I am going to get married with this lady. Even I told you everything. Do you want to come back? Still, I am coming. I want to come back to you.
我告诉过你，我要和这位女士结婚。甚至我把一切都告诉你了。你想回来吗？我还想回来。我想回到你身边。
You know, I said, you're getting married, for god sake. He said, well, yeah, but actually, you are my wife.
你知道，我说，你都要结婚了，天哪。他说，好吧，是的，但实际上，你才是我的妻子。
Suddenly, she started crying, very bad. I was worried about her. I was very, very upset again. I didn't know what should I do now.
突然，她开始哭得很厉害。我担心她。我又非常非常难过。我不知道我现在该做什么。
My dad was two weeks away from going to collect his new bride. He felt awful about standing her up, but he'd never stopped loving my mom, even though he'd spent the last two years trying to forget about her. And so he didn't really have a choice.
我父亲离去迎娶新娘还有两周。他对自己要爽约感到非常糟糕，但他从未停止爱我母亲，尽管他花了过去两年试图忘记她。所以他真的别无选择。
My dad promised my mom that he'd changed, but she didn't want to move too fast. So my parents, for the first time in their lives ever, started dating-- well, sort of. On their first date, they didn't leave the house.
我父亲向我母亲保证他已经改变了，但她不想发展得太快。所以我的父母，一生中第一次，开始约会了——嗯，差不多吧。在他们的第一次约会上，他们没有离开家。
He came to my house. And you know, we talked. And in fact, I cried all throughout.
他来到我家。你知道，我们谈了谈。事实上，我哭了一整晚。
Why are you crying now? Do you know? Is it because-- have you not talked-- is it because you haven't talked about this for a while?
你为什么现在在哭？你知道吗？是因为——你还没谈过——是因为你有一段时间没谈论这个了吗？
Well, I think, when I look back, whole thing was a sad event. And you know, I just told him, you know, what have we done regarding that point? He said, well, I did tons of mistakes, but you were with me with all those mistakes. Because you should have, you know been firmer. You should have let me know that how much you hate me.
嗯，我想，当我回首往事，整个事件是一次令人悲伤的经历。你知道，我只是告诉他，关于那一点我们做了什么？他说，嗯，我犯了很多错误，但你一直陪伴着我，包容那些错误。因为你应该，你知道，更坚定一点。你应该让我知道你有多讨厌我。
You never told me that you hate me. You never told me that you were that much upset. You always said, yes, yes, yes, yes, and-- you know? And he listened. You know, I told him everything, and he never got upset, or never got offended, or never got red and blue, or-- you know?
你从来没告诉过我你讨厌我。你从来没告诉过我你那么难过。你总是说，是，是，是，是，然后——你知道吗？他倾听了。你知道，我告诉了他一切，他从来没有难过，从来没有感到被冒犯，从来没有气得脸红脖子粗——你知道吗？
So I told him everything that I was upset about that I never had the guts to tell him. And he listened. And he said, you're absolutely right. I lost you. You were the most precious thing that I ever got. And so I want to fix that, if you let me.
所以我告诉了他我感到难过的所有事情，我以前没有勇气告诉他的事情。他倾听了。他说，你是绝对正确的。我失去了你。你是我得到的最宝贵的东西。所以我想弥补这一点，如果你允许的话。
It was kind of relief, yeah. We had a lot of information. We have to release for 25 years' marriage what parts we did wrong and what part it was OK.
这是一种解脱，是的。我们获得了很多信息。我们必须释放25年婚姻中我们做错的地方，以及哪些部分是还可以的。
After our conversation and after he went to leave, he hugged me, and he said, you know, just let's try one more time, and let's see how it's going to go. And he hugged me, and I thought, oh, my god, feels good. [LAUGHS] I thought I fall into a shoulder that I can rely.
谈话结束后，在他离开之前，他拥抱了我，他说，你知道，咱们再试一次，看看结果会怎样。他拥抱了我，我想，哦，天哪，感觉真好。[笑] 我想我落入了一个我可以依靠的肩膀。
The second courtship took six months, instead of three weeks. They got married at City Hall. Everyone they knew was overjoyed, except for my sister and me. We boycotted the wedding. It seemed ridiculous to us. After three years of worrying about them and holding their hands, they were heading straight back into the misery they'd worked so hard to leave behind.
第二次求爱持续了六个月，而不是三周。他们在市政厅结了婚。所有认识他们的人都欣喜若狂，除了我和我妹妹。我们抵制了婚礼。对我们来说这看起来太荒谬了。在为他们担心了三年并牵着他们的手之后，他们又径直走回了他们努力想离开的痛苦之中。
But it turns out we were wrong. They traded their unhappy Iranian marriage for a happy American one. When you think about American relationships, you think about the divorces, the self-help books, the constant talking about feelings. And even though all of that seems undignified and laughable, it's all working for my parents.
但事实证明我们错了。他们用不幸的伊朗婚姻换取了幸福的美国式婚姻。当你想到美国式的关系时，你会想到离婚、自助书籍、不断谈论感受。即使这一切看起来既不庄重又可笑，但对我的父母来说都奏效了。
Now I can see my dad struggling to keep his temper in check. He thinks about hurting my mom now, about embarrassing her in a way he never did before. I see them laugh with each other and talk to each other.
现在我可以看到父亲在努力控制脾气。他现在会考虑伤害母亲的事，考虑以一种他以前从未有过的方式让她尴尬。我看到他们互相交谈、开怀大笑。
I used to be so nervous around them, because the atmosphere was so tense. Now, they actually seem to like each other. And for a long time, I attributed everything to my father's change. He learned to control his temper, and now they're happy. But that's not the way they see it.
我以前在他们身边很紧张，因为气氛太紧张了。现在，他们似乎真的喜欢对方。很长一段时间里，我把一切归功于父亲的改变。他学会了控制脾气，现在他们幸福了。但这并不是他们的看法。
Divorce, I think, is changed Mina more than me also, a lot.
我想，离婚改变米娜比改变我也多得多。
Basically, I had a lot of problem in my life that he wasn't the cause of it. When two years I sat down, I always thought, he's not here. I still have those problems, you know? I don't socialize not because of-- it's not him, it's me.
基本上，我生活中有很多问题不是他造成的。当我坐下来那两年，我总是想，他不在了。我仍然有那些问题，你知道？我不社交不是因为……不是他，是我自己。
Living on her own allowed my mother to see my father the way he'd always seen her-- as a choice she wanted to make. And now she says she loves him for the first time in her life.
独自生活让我母亲能够用他一直看待她的眼光看待我父亲——作为她想要做出的一个选择。现在她说她一生中第一次爱上了他。
Everybody agrees that if they'd stayed in Iran, none of this would have happened-- not the heartbreak, not the new-found compatibility. This is my sister, Nilofar.
大家都同意，如果他们留在伊朗，这一切都不会发生——没有心碎，也没有新发现的契合度。这是我的妹妹，尼洛法。
The West did break them up. And then, they had the freedom to get back together again, you know? I always felt like we had such a weirdly and kind of such an American experience, like, all of a sudden in the middle. And I don't know what even that means except that my parents got divorced, and then they talked about their feelings, and they both went to therapy. And my dad read Men are From Mars, Women are From Venus.
西方确实让他们分开了。然后，他们又有了重新在一起的自由，你知道吗？我一直觉得我们的经历很奇怪，甚至有点美国式的，就像中间突然出现的那样。我不知道那意味着什么，只知道我的父母离婚了，然后他们谈论了各自的感受，他们俩都去接受了治疗。而且我父亲读了《男人来自火星，女人来自金星》。
He did, among other things.
他确实读了，还有其他书。
And we talked to my dad about relationships. And he started dating. And I was just like-- it's like I feel like we had this family, like the crazy family on the block who doesn't put up Christmas lights, like the non-American, crazy family.
我们和父亲谈论过人际关系。他开始约会。我就觉得——我觉得我们就像那个社区里古怪的家庭，那种不挂圣诞彩灯的，不那么美国化的、疯狂的家庭。
With a bad lawn.
还有杂草丛生的草坪。
With a bad lawn all of our lives. And then all of a sudden, my parents turned All-American and had this American experience. And now we're like this little happy family. And it kind of grosses me out too, because I'm like, this is not where we fit. You know? This is not our family. You know what I mean?
一辈子都有糟糕的草坪。然后突然之间，我的父母变成了地道的美国人，有了这种美国式的体验。现在我们就像这个小小的幸福家庭。这甚至让我觉得恶心，因为我就想，这不适合我们。你知道吗？这不是我们的家庭。你明白我的意思吗？
I love it.
我喜欢。
I think it's great. I love it. It feels really normal and good now.
我觉得这很好。我喜欢它。现在感觉真的很正常，很好。
I'm still struggling with normal and good. When you thought about your life as some slightly depressing, slightly boring novel lying on the bargain bookshelf, it's weird to have it end up on the bestseller rack in the self-help section.
我还在努力适应“正常和美好”。当你把生活想成那种放在廉价书架上有点压抑、有点无聊的小说时，结局最终出现在自助类书籍的畅销书架上是很奇怪的。
[MUSIC - MILES DAVIS, "SOMEDAY MY PRINCE WILL COME"]
[音乐 - 迈尔斯·戴维斯，《某天我的王子会来》]
Nazanin Rafsanjani. In the years since we first broadcast that story, she was on the podcast Startup many times. And she now heads new show development for the podcast company Gimlet Media. Her parents are still together.
纳扎宁·拉夫桑贾尼。在我们首次播出那个故事后的几年里，她多次出现在《创业》播客中。她现在负责播客公司Gimlet Media的新节目开发。她的父母仍然在一起。
Coming up, a reunion that attempts to defy the most powerful force on Earth. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一场试图反抗地球上最强大力量的重聚。一分钟后，当我们的节目从芝加哥公共广播电台继续播出时，让我们一起来看。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Reunited (And it Feels So Good)," stories of unlikely reunions achieved through the most difficult paths possible. And we've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“重聚（感觉真好）”，讲述通过尽可能困难的路径实现的不可思议的重聚故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, "And If By Chance We Meet Again." There's an old story about a reunion that goes like this. There was Orpheus, and there was Eurydice. They were young. They were in love. And just after they married, she died an untimely death.
第二幕，“如果缘分让我们再次相遇”。有一个关于重聚的古老故事是这样的。那是俄耳甫斯和欧律狄刻。他们很年轻。他们坠入爱河。他们刚结婚不久，她就英年早逝。
And his love was so great that he went to the gates of the underworld, tried things nobody had ever done to try to bring her back to life. And for a little while, just a little while, it seemed like he had succeeded. This next story is just like that, except it's about a bull.
他的爱如此伟大，以至于他去了冥界的大门，尝试了没人做过的事情，试图让她起死回生。有一小段时间，仅仅一小段时间，看起来他似乎成功了。接下来的故事就像那样，只不过它是关于一头公牛的。
He's just like a big bundle of just loving whatever. If you've ever had a favorite dog that you can think of as a child, or some other animal-- and he'd lick your face, you know? And yes, he was cuddly.
他简直就是一个充满爱的化身。如果你曾经养过一只像孩子一样的宠物狗，或其他动物——他会舔你的脸，你知道吗？是的，他很讨人喜欢。
"Cuddly" is not usually the word you used to describe a full-grown Brahman bull. They're white, regal, ancient-looking, with huge horns and a blackened hump the size of a bowling ball that rises between their shoulders.
“讨人喜欢”通常不是用来形容成年婆罗门公牛的词。它们通体雪白，威严，看起来很古老，有着巨大的角，肩膀间隆起着像保龄球那么大的黑色驼峰。
[BULL SNORT]
[公牛鼻息声]
That muscle right there is the one that throws all the bull riders off. When they flex that muscle, the rope just pops right out of their hand, and they're long gone. Yes, you're a good boy. Yeah.
那块肌肉正是让所有骑牛者摔下来的地方。当他们弯曲那块肌肉时，绳子就会从他们的手中弹出来，他们就飞出去了。是的，你是好孩子。是的。
Bulls usually don't even want you near them.
公牛通常甚至不想让你靠近它们。
Come on, buddy.
来吧，伙计。
Now, Ralph Fisher had been around bulls and steer all his life. He'd worked the rodeo as a young man. He'd trained animals as an adult. When he found Chance at an auction, he'd never seen a bull so tame. His kids would climb all over Chance. Chance would nuzzle up to Ralph's wife, Sandra, and lean his head.
拉尔夫·费舍尔一生都在和公牛与阉牛打交道。他年轻时在牛仔竞技表演中工作。他成年后训练过动物。当他在拍卖会上发现“机会”时，他从没见过如此温顺的公牛。他的孩子们会爬在“机会”身上。它会去蹭拉尔夫的妻子桑德拉，靠着她的头。
It really is like having a pet dog or a pet cat, except the size.
这真的就像养了一只宠物狗或宠物猫，除了体型大了点。
But they seem so much less demonstrative, you know?
但它们看起来没那么爱表现，对吧？
Wrong-- [LAUGHS]
错—— [笑]
Really?
真的吗？
That's wrong.
那是错的。
I don't know if Ralph and Sandra would agree with this, but I think everything that went bad, all the trouble that eventually unfolded, it all came because they were blinded by their feelings.
我不知道拉尔夫和桑德拉是否同意这一点，但我认为所有变坏的事情，所有最终发生的麻烦，都是因为他们被自己的感情蒙蔽了。
With the world's largest Herd of saddle-broke tame Texas Longhorns and Brahmans, Ralph Fisher's photo animals are sure to be a crowd-pleaser at your corporate gathering, convention, sales meeting, or even at your own private party.
拥有世界上最大的鞍下温顺德克萨斯长角牛和婆罗门牛群，拉尔夫·费舍尔的摄影动物一定会成为您的企业聚会、会议、销售会议甚至私人派对上的亮点。
Ralph and Sandra have a family business taking pictures of people standing next to or on top of animals at barbecues, parties, the occasional presidential inaugural ball. And Chance was the star. This is their promotional video. They did dozens of shots of people sitting on Chance, one after another.
拉尔夫和桑德拉有一家家庭企业，专门在烧烤、派对、偶尔的总统就职舞会上，拍人们站在动物旁边或骑在动物身上的照片。“机会”就是明星。这是他们的宣传视频。他们给人们骑在“机会”身上的镜头拍了几十次，一张接一张。
With $1 million liability insurance, beautiful tame animals, and state of the art photo equipment, we furnish your clients and guests with a lasting memory of your Texas event.
拥有100万美元的责任保险，美丽温顺的动物，以及最先进的摄影设备，我们为您的客户和客人提供德克萨斯活动的持久回忆。
Because of the business, Chance is possibly the most photographed bull who's ever lived. Chance met Ashley Judd and Roger Clements, Mother Theresa and Sonny Bono-- those were separate meetings-- Hitman Hearns, Sugar Ray Leonard, Dan Rather. Chance did the Letterman Show.
因为这项业务，“机会”可能是历史上被拍摄最多的公牛。它见过艾什莉·贾德和罗杰·克莱门斯、特蕾莎修女和桑尼·波诺——那些是单独的会面——希特曼·赫恩斯、舒格·雷·伦纳德、丹·拉瑟。它还上过大卫·莱特曼秀。
You know, this animal, certain parts of this animal, it looks like he's shoplifting sporting goods.
你知道，这只动物的某些部分，看起来它像是在商店里偷窃运动器材。
Chance was in a movie with Vince Vaughn.
“机会”还和文斯·沃恩演过电影。
That sure is a handsome bull.
那确实是一头帅气的公牛。
Yes, sir. That's about the handsomest bull I've seen in all my days of cattle ranching.
是的，先生。那是我一生放牧牛群以来见过的最帅气的公牛。
In the movie, Jeremy Davies plays a guy who doesn't talk to people, but does talk to Chance, which all builds to this climactic scene where, for reasons that are not exactly clear, Kate Capshaw castrates Chance in the middle of the night in a driving rainstorm, just to prove a point.
在电影中，杰里米·戴维斯饰演一个不与人交流，但与“机会”说话的人，这一切构建了那个高潮场景，由于原因不太明确，凯特·卡普肖在深夜大雨中阉割了“机会”，仅仅是为了证明一个观点。
Now, you watch this, because I'm only gonna show you once.
现在，你看好，因为我只给你演示一次。
(SUBJECT) Oh, no!
(受试者) 哦，不！
[BULL BELLOWS]
[公牛吼叫]
So Sandra and Ralph had this really sweet situation. They got to work side-by-side with all these animals, which they loved. Chance was so tame that he was allowed out of the pasture and even had a favorite spot in the front yard, under the trees. Sandra would watch him from the kitchen window, which was a really nice feeling. You'd be doing the dishes, and you'd look out, and there's your tame pet bull, like Ferdinand, laying on the grass.
所以桑德拉和拉尔夫有这种非常甜蜜的情况。他们可以和他们热爱的所有动物并肩工作。它温顺到被允许离开牧场，甚至在院子里的树下有自己最喜欢的休息点。桑德拉会从厨房窗户看着它，那感觉真的很好。你在洗碗，往外看，那是你的温顺宠物公牛，像斐迪南一样躺在草地上。
Then, a rainy day in September, Chance didn't come in from the pasture to eat. Sandra went looking for him. And finally, Ralph headed out to the pasture and found him dead. He was 19, which was really old for a bull.
然后，九月的一个雨天，“机会”没有从牧场回来吃东西。桑德拉去寻找它。最后，拉尔夫前往牧场发现了它已经死了。它19岁了，对公牛来说真的非常老了。
It was a really a sad day. I took the camera out, and I was going to take some pictures. And then I said, well, you know, he deserves more than that. So I skinned him. I skinned his whole body. It took me all day. It was raining.
那真是悲伤的一天。我拿出相机，想拍些照片。然后我说，嗯，你知道，它值得比这更多。所以我剥了它的皮。我剥了它全身的皮。花了我一整天。当时正在下雨。
So it was a really sad time. I'd skin a while, and cry a while. I was just like a baby, just crying like a baby out there with my knife, you know, skinning him. And I'm going, well, somebody has to do this. And I'd have to toughen up and regroup. And this lasted all day long. And I guess I was a complete wreck by the time it was all over with
所以那是一段非常悲伤的时光。我剥一会儿皮，哭一会儿。我就像个婴儿，在外面拿着刀哭得像个婴儿，你知道，剥着它的皮。我心想，好吧，总得有人做这件事。我得坚强起来，重整旗鼓。这持续了一整天。我猜当这一切结束时，我彻底崩溃了。
Ralph says he had no choice. He had to skin him in the first 24 hours, because he wanted to get him taxidermied, turn him into a full-sized Brahman statue, have been around forever. And people could still have their picture taken with him. Chance could stay in the family business.
拉尔夫说他别无选择。他必须在24小时内剥皮，因为他想把它做成标本，把它变成一尊全尺寸的婆罗门公牛雕像，让它永远存在。这样人们仍然可以和它合影。“机会”可以留在家族企业里。
So I was so emotional-- everything was really emotional. And all the family had a good cry too-- all of my kids and the people who knew him so long. They all just hated that.
所以我太情绪化了——一切都真的很感性。所有的家人也都痛哭了一场——我所有的孩子和认识它很久的人。他们都讨厌这样。
OK, rewind. Three months before all that happened, Ralph heard about this way that he might be able to cheat death with Chance and keep him around. It was more than taxidermy, but it was a real long shot.
好吧，倒带。在这所有事情发生前三个月，拉尔夫听说了一种他可能能够用“机会”欺骗死亡并将它留住的方法。那不仅仅是标本制作，但这是一个真正渺茫的机会。
Someone called me and said, we've read an article in the paper that A&M is going to clone an animal. What do you mean, "clone?" They said, you know, clone, make one from another one. I said, oh, no, it can't be.
有人打电话给我说，我们读了一篇报纸文章，说德州农工大学要克隆一只动物。你说的“克隆”是什么意思？他们说，你知道，克隆，制造一个和另一个一样的。我说，哦，不，不可能。
A&M is Texas A&M, a world-famous veterinary school and animal hospital. It just happens to be an hour and a half drive from Ralph's house. It was Chance's regular hospital.
德州农工大学是一所世界著名的兽医学校和动物医院。它刚好距离拉尔夫家有1.5小时的车程。那是“机会”经常去的医院。
And so we called up and said, you know, you're going to clone an animal, right? They said, yes, we take tissue and we-- and we said, well, why don't you use Chance? And so other folks would call, then. Some friends would call and talk to him. And they finally just-- I think we bothered them so much, they gave up. They said, OK, well, we'll do it.
于是我们打电话说，你知道，你们要克隆一只动物，对吧？他们说，是的，我们取组织，然后……我们说，好吧，你们为什么不用“机会”呢？其他亲友也打电话过来。他们最终……我想我们骚扰得他们实在受不了了，他们放弃了。他们说，好吧，我们会做的。
In the end, the scientists decided to clone Chance for a simple reason-- he was old. There were some things they thought they might find out by cloning an older animal. And Chance was there anyway, getting a mole biopsied for disease. The scientists could use the DNA from the mole to do their cloning.
最后，科学家们决定克隆“机会”，原因很简单——它很老。他们认为通过克隆一只年长的动物可能会发现一些事情。而且“机会”当时刚好在那儿，正在为一个患病的痣做活检。科学家可以使用痣中的DNA进行克隆。
In Texas tonight, a man, his wife, and their bull have been reunited.
今晚在德克萨斯，一个男人、他的妻子和他们的公牛重聚了。
Yeah, I guess he's been reincarnated.
是的，我猜它已经轮回转世了。
10 months and 18 days after Chance died, the long shot paid off. A clone was born-- the first cloned bull. It was huge news. And it was Ralph who figured out what to call Chance's clone.
“机会”死后10个月18天，这个渺茫的机会成功了。一个克隆体出生了——第一头克隆公牛。这是一个巨大的新闻。是拉尔夫想出了给这个克隆体叫什么名字。
Second Chance. And he was just the prettiest little white Brahman calf you ever saw. And spindly. And barely able to stand.
“第二次机会”。它是你见过的最可爱的婆罗门小牛犊。瘦骨嶙峋。几乎站不稳。
I thought it was the same animal. I would say, you know, we got him back. That's the first headline, I think, in the news clippings when they interviewed me-- we got him back.
我认为它就是同一只动物。我想，你知道，我们把它找回来了。我想，当他们采访我时，那是新闻剪报里的第一个标题——我们找回它了。
The vets at A&M would ask us, or kidded with us about whether the calf was going to recognize his own stall in the barn when we got him home. But we sort of blew that off.
德州农工大学的兽医会问我们，或者开玩笑地问我们，当我们把它带回家时，它是否会认出它在谷仓里的隔间。但我们没当回事。
Well, the first day we brought him home, we turned him loose over here in the yard. And he went over and laid down in the same spot. This still kind of chokes me up. He laid down in the same spot that Chance laid in, you know? That's not reasonable.
嗯，第一天我们把它带回家，我们在院子里把它放开。它走过去躺在同一个位置。这仍然让我有点哽咽。它躺在“机会”躺过的同一个位置，你知道吗？这不合理。
And it all was spooky. That was spooky.
这一切都很诡异。这很诡异。
The other thing they noticed right away with Second Chances is that he has Chance's same mannerisms when he eats-- unusual mannerisms. Instead of putting his head into a feed bucket and holding it down there and chewing until there's no more food, both Chance and Second Chance raise their heads, close their eyes, and chew.
他们注意到的关于“第二次机会”的另一件事是，它有和“机会”吃东西时一样的习惯——不同寻常的习惯。它们不是把头伸进饲料桶，一直低头嚼到没有食物为止，相反，“机会”和“第二次机会”都会抬起头，闭上眼睛，慢慢咀嚼。
I've never seen another animal do that. I've never seen another animal do that.
我从没见过其他动物那样做。我从没见过其他动物那样做。
And there's something else about Second Chance, something harder to quantify.
“第二次机会”还有别的东西，更难量化。
I just feel like he always recognized Ralph Fisher. And Ralph would lay down on the ground, and Second Chance would lick him and lick his boots. And Second Chance would lope across the pasture and come to us. And we watched other people. Vets would crawl in there, and he wouldn't come across the pasture to them. He just always seemed to recognize Ralph.
我只是觉得它总是认出拉尔夫·费舍尔。拉尔夫会躺在地上，“第二次机会”会舔他，舔他的靴子。“第二次机会”会穿过牧场向我们奔来。我们观察其他人。兽医会爬进去，它不会穿过牧场走向他们。它似乎总是认出拉尔夫。
And what did you think? Did you think somehow his memory got transferred?
你当时怎么想？你觉得某种方式上它的记忆转移了吗？
Well, no. I still don't think that. I think that he just has the same instincts, the same-- that he's going to make the same choices. Why would the eating thing be the same?
嗯，没有。我仍然不这么认为。我觉得它只是有同样的本能，同样的……它会做出同样的选择。为什么吃东西的习惯会一样？
A clone is akin to a genetically identical twin. It's not the same animal. It's not Chance.
克隆体类似于基因完全相同的双胞胎。它不是同一只动物。它不是“机会”。
Dr. Mark Westhusin is one of the scientists who runs the Reproductive Sciences Lab at Texas A&M, the lab that cloned Second Chance. And he says that because a clone is just a twin-- nothing more, nothing less-- it may not even look the same as the original. And just like twins, clones don't necessarily act like the originals either. But Dr. Westhusin understands how Ralph or Sandra may not see it that way.
马克·韦斯胡森博士是运营德州农工大学生殖科学实验室的科学家之一，就是那个克隆了“第二次机会”的实验室。他说，因为克隆体只是一个双胞胎——不多不少——它甚至看起来可能和原件不一样。而且就像双胞胎一样，克隆体也不一定像原型那样行事。但韦斯胡森博士理解为什么拉尔夫或桑德拉可能不这么看。
Well, people get attached to their animals, and they-- you know? And they want to, sometimes, see more than is there. And they do see more than is, maybe, really there. And that's not necessarily a bad thing. I mean, that's like--
嗯，人们对他们的动物有感情，而且他们……你知道吗？他们有时想看到比实际存在更多的东西。他们确实看到了比实际存在的更多的东西。这不一定是坏事。我是说，这就像……
That's love, right there.
那就是爱，对吧？
Yeah, that's love. That's not necessarily a bad thing. And it was interesting for me to listen to Ralph tell how he lies under the same tree, and he eats his food just the same as the old Chance did. And I'm like, that's really cool, Ralph, you know? But I just-- how's his blood glucose today? [LAUGHS] I'm interested in that, you know?
是的，那是爱。这不一定是坏事。听拉尔夫说它如何躺在同一棵树下，吃食物的方式和老“机会”一模一样，这对我来说很有趣。我心想，这真的太酷了，拉尔夫。但我只是……它今天的血糖怎么样？[笑] 我对那个感兴趣，你知道吗？
Dr. Westhusin reminded me several times, this is not the same animal. Don't expect the same attitude from a pet. And I didn't believe him, because everything looked the same. Just when I see him, especially at a distance, he looks so much like Chance. And every day, as he gets older and older, so much.
韦斯胡森博士提醒过我几次，这不是同一只动物。不要指望宠物有同样的态度。我当时不相信他，因为一切看起来都一样。当我看到它时，尤其是在远处，它看起来太像“机会”了。而且每天，随着它越来越大，越来越像。
Every year on Second Chance's birthday, Ralph and Sandra would throw a party for him, fire up some barbecue-- which, if you think about it, would be so disturbing for the guest of honor, if only he knew. Anyway, on his fourth birthday, all the family, and friends, and neighbors came to the front yard, posed for pictures with Second Chance.
在“第二次机会”生日那天，拉尔夫和桑德拉会为它举办派对，烤些烧烤——如果你想一想，如果被邀请的嘉宾知道真相，这会让人多么不安。总之，在它四岁生日时，所有的家人、朋友和邻居都来到前院，和“第二次机会”合影。
We had his birthday cake, which is a big feed tub with candles on top. And we blew the candles out. And I said, it's about dark, so I think I'll lead him back to the barn.
我们有它的生日蛋糕，那是一个放着蜡烛的大饲料桶。我们吹灭了蜡烛。我说，天快黑了，我想我带它回谷仓。
I put one finger in his nose ring, which is a common thing. It gives you close contact. And if they make any aggression, you can immediately feel it and respond, you know?
我把一根手指塞进它的鼻环里，这是一种常见的做法。这能让你有近距离接触。如果它们有任何攻击倾向，你可以立即感觉到并做出反应，你知道吗？
Anyway, I was walking him. We just did a few steps out of the yard, and I had the lead rope in the other hand. We just took a few steps, and then, boom, caught me with his horn and slammed me down. And that's when he dislocated my shoulder. Hit me in the back, so I was immobile on that side. He picked me up and [MAKES WHOOSH NOISE] slammed me down, you see?
总之，我在牵着它走。我们刚走出院子几步，我另一只手拿着牵引绳。我们刚走了几步，然后，砰，它用角顶住我，把我猛摔在地。那就是它让我的肩膀脱臼的时候。撞在我的背上，所以我那一侧动弹不得。它把我挑起来，[发出嗖的一声]猛摔下去，你明白吗？
And then he proceeded to get on top of me with mostly his head, his forehead, and his horns. We found three deep, deep holes, six or eight inches, in the yard that next day where he had missed me. And he was really trying-- he was really attacking. It was like, you know, on purpose.
然后它开始用它的头部，主要是前额和角骑在我身上。第二天，我们在院子里发现了三个很深很深的洞，六到八英寸，它本来应该把我戳穿的。它真的是在尝试——它真的是在攻击。就好像，你知道，它是故意的。
Oh, no. I said, oh no, this can't be. This can't be happening. Because we had had so much faith in him. And you know, oh, it just-- you know, I didn't-- at that time, all I was thinking about was, why are you doing this? Why? And I was just so disappointed the whole time. I remember, when I was kicking him in the face, I was just going, how could you be doing this to me? Quit it. I think my feelings-- he actually hurt my pride.
哦，不。我说，哦，不，这不可能。这不可能发生。因为我们对它有太多的信任。你知道，这真的……那时，我满脑子想的只是，你为什么这样做？为什么？我一直感到非常失望。我记得当我踢它的脸时，我只是在想，你怎么能对我做这种事？住手。我想我的感受——它确实伤害了我的自尊。
Since the attack, Ralph acknowledges Second Chance is not the same animal as Chance. And he believes it. He definitely believes it.
自那次袭击以来，拉尔夫承认“第二次机会”和“机会”不是同一只动物。他相信了。他绝对相信了。
When you love, you see what you want to see. Everybody knows that. And part of him still holds out hope-- hope that even if Second Chance is not Chance right now, he'll turn into Chance, they'll still get their reunion.
当你去爱的时候，你只看到你想看到的东西。每个人都知道这一点。他内心深处仍然抱有希望——希望即使“第二次机会”现在不是“机会”，它也会变成“机会”，他们仍然能实现重聚。
Well, the hope is involving his age, since I did not have chance until he was almost seven years old.
嗯，希望与它的年龄有关，因为直到它快七岁时我才拥有“机会”。
Right.
对。
I don't really know how Second Chance is supposed to act.
我真的不知道“第二次机会”应该怎么表现。
Oh, you don't know if Chance was just like this back in the day?
哦，你不知道“机会”以前是不是也这样？
Right. Right. So he might just have to go through a little stage and settle down. I know horses settle down. My Texas Longhorns settle down.
对。对。所以它可能只是要经历一个小的阶段然后沉淀下来。我知道马会沉淀下来。我的德克萨斯长角牛也会沉淀下来。
Ralph, here's one of things that I've been really wondering about your situation. I wonder if having Second Chance around all the time is ever painful for you, because it reminds you that you don't have Chance? It's like, here, you have this ghost of your favorite animal walking the property, who isn't exactly Chance, and if it just kind of breaks your heart a little bit?
拉尔夫，关于你的情况，我一直很好奇一件事。我想知道身边一直有“第二次机会”是否让你感到痛苦，因为它提醒你你没有“机会”了？就像，这里有你最喜欢的动物的幽灵在你的地盘上走来走去，但它并不是真正的“机会”，这是否有点让你心碎？
No, sir, it's just the opposite. You're just exactly as wrong as you can be. So far, right now, I feel like we've gotten about 95% of him back-- I mean, the same qualities, the same fun. That satisfies me. That's better than zero.
不，先生，恰恰相反。你错得离谱。到目前为止，我觉得我们已经找回了它95%的特质——我是说，同样的品质，同样的乐趣。这让我满足了。这总比零好。
When he was laying out in that pasture out there dead, he was a zero. I mean, we would never have any enjoyment out of him any more. And there's a tremendous difference between 0 and 95%.
当它躺在那个牧场里死去时，它就是零。我是说，我们再也不会从它身上得到任何乐趣了。而在0和95%之间有巨大的差别。
People want to believe it is resurrection, sometimes. And it is, in fact, not resurrection. It's reproduction.
人们有时希望相信这是复活。但实际上，这不是复活。这是复制。
This is bad news Dr. Westhusin has had to deliver to a lot of people over the years. It was his lab at Texas A&M that cloned the first house pet, that cloned a cat named CC. It was international news.
这是韦斯胡森博士多年来不得不向许多人传达的坏消息。正是他在德州农工大学的实验室克隆了第一只家养宠物，克隆了一只叫“CC”的猫。那是国际新闻。
And for a while, his lab got a lot of money from investors who wanted to start a business cloning people's pets-- which they've gotten away from now. But for a while, the scientists were deluged with calls from pet owners, people who wanted what Ralph and Sandra wanted-- they wanted their animals back.
有一段时间，他的实验室从投资者那里得到了很多钱，这些人想开办一家克隆人们宠物的企业——他们现在已经不做了。但有一段时间，科学家们被宠物主人打来的电话淹没了，这些人想要拉尔夫和桑德拉想要的东西——他们想要回他们的动物。
You know, some were like, I have hair in the jewelry box that I've kept for 10 years. And will that work? No. You know, I had several calls where the animals had already been buried, and they were so-- you know, I didn't think about this till after I buried him. Do you think there'd be any possibility we could go out in the yard and dig it up and get some tissues to clone this animal back?
你知道，有些人说，我首饰盒里留着它10年前的毛发。那管用吗？不。你知道，我有几次接到电话，动物已经埋葬了，他们说……你知道，我埋了它之后才想到这一点。你认为我们有可能去院子里把它挖出来，拿点组织来克隆这个动物吗？
And I'm just like, well, no, I don't think so. It's going to be pretty ran and full of bacteria. And we probably will not be able to get the tissue. And they'd say, well, it's cold up here, you know? And it was frozen when we did it, so I'm sure the carcass is still frozen. And it hasn't deteriorated too much. What do you think?
我只是说，嗯，不，我不这么认为。那会腐烂且充满细菌。我们可能无法获得组织。他们会说，嗯，这里很冷，你知道？我们做的时候它是冻住的，所以我确定尸体现在还是冻住的。它没有腐烂太多。你怎么看？
When I visited Ralph's ranch to interview him and Sandra, it had been about a year and a half since the birthday party where Second Chance attacked Ralph. There were a bunch of us on this trip, including a film crew. And one night while we were taping up by the house, we heard a scream. And one of the crew came running up from the barn where Ralph and Second Chance were.
当我访问拉尔夫的牧场去采访他和桑德拉时，距离“第二次机会”攻击拉尔夫的生日派对已经过去了一年半了。我们此行有很多人，包括一个拍摄组。一天晚上，当我们在房子附近录像时，我们听到了一声尖叫。其中一个工作人员从拉尔夫和“第二次机会”所在的谷仓跑过来。
[INAUDIBLE]?
[听不清]？
What?
什么？
You guys?
你们？
What?
什么？
[INAUDIBLE], the bull attacked him.
[听不清]，公牛攻击了他。
Who?
谁？
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
The bull attacked him. What's the address here?
公牛攻击了他。这里的地址是什么？
We threw Ralph into a car and rushed him into town to the nearest hospital. He was banged up pretty badly. Finally, Sandra came out from the emergency room to tell us that he'd be getting 80 stitches where Second Chance gored him.
我们把拉尔夫塞进车里，急忙把他送到镇上最近的医院。他受了重伤。最后，桑德拉从急诊室出来告诉我们，他缝了80针，是“第二次机会”顶伤的。
The doctor is examining him right now.
医生正在给他检查。
Yeah. And he gored him, like, in his crotch?
是的。它顶伤了他的，像，胯部？
It's his left scrotum is ripped, and his testicle's hanging out. [SIGHS]
它的左侧阴囊被撕裂了，睾丸露出来了。[叹气]
Oh, god.
哦，天哪。
One of the producers of This American Life, Jane Marie, was in the barn, and she saw the attack. She says Ralph was bringing Second Chance some feed, trying to back him into a pen, when Second Chances just tossed Ralph.
《美国生活》的一位制片人简·玛丽当时在谷仓里，她目睹了这次袭击。她说，当时拉尔夫正给“第二次机会”拿饲料，试图把它赶回围栏，“第二次机会”就直接顶翻了拉尔夫。
I screamed. And I didn't want to look at it because I thought he was going to kill him, you know? And I didn't want--
我尖叫起来。我不想看，因为我以为它会杀了他，你知道吗？我不想——
And what did you see?
你看到了什么？
I just saw him fly up in the air, and then the bull-- it was loud. It seemed really loud, because it was at the corner of the fence. So he threw up in the air, and he landed on the corner of the fences. And he's ramming him in the ground, into the fence. So the fences are all shaking, and the bull's making all the noises.
我只看到他飞到空中，然后那头公牛——声音很大。声音听起来真的很大，因为它是在栅栏的角落。所以他被顶到空中，落在栅栏的角落。它在地上撞他，撞向栅栏。栅栏都在震动，公牛发出各种声音。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
And it seems like the bull's going to break through the fences after he's done killing him, you know what I mean? It was very, very loud, very, very fast.
看起来那头公牛在杀了他之后还要冲破栅栏，你懂我的意思吗？声音非常非常大，非常非常快。
It's almost like Second Chance was trying to tell Ralph that he's not Chance, using the only language he has. And of course, he's not Chance. In movies and books, when somebody tries to bring back a loved one from the dead-- whether it's a pet, or if it's a person-- it never works out well. It's one of the all-time ranking bad ideas, right up there with deciding to give robots and computers human feelings, or going back in time to change just one little thing in the past.
简直就像“第二次机会”在尝试用它唯一拥有的语言告诉拉尔夫，它不是“机会”。当然，它不是“机会”。在电影和书中，当有人试图带回已故的爱人时——无论是宠物还是人——结果总是很糟。这是史上评价最差的主意之一，和给机器人和计算机赋予人类感情，或者回到过去只改变一件小事一样糟糕。
The next day, we were finally allowed to see Ralph in his hospital room.
第二天，我们终于被允许在病房里见到拉尔夫。
So Ralph, how are you feeling?
拉尔夫，你感觉怎么样？
Oh, I feel good. They had me up walking this morning, first thing. I've walked the block in the hospital about four times now, and the last two without any help.
哦，我感觉很好。今天一早他们就让我下床走路了。我已经围着医院走了大约四圈，最后两圈还没人帮忙。
There was a scar on his nose. His lip and chin were busted. His spine, we found out later, had a hairline fracture.
他的鼻梁上有疤。他的嘴唇和下巴被打肿了。我们后来发现他的脊椎有一处细微骨折。
So you were saying when we talked before that you felt like, with Second Chance, what you've got is 95% of what Chance was. And I wonder if, after this incident, you might downgrade him to just, like, 80%, or 70%?
所以你之前谈到，你觉得有了“第二次机会”，你找回了“机会”95%的特质。我想知道，发生这件事后，你是否会把它降级为80%或70%？
[LAUGHING] No, because this is exactly the same type incident as when he butted me 18 months ago, a year and a half ago, when he--
[大笑] 不会，因为这和我18个月前被它顶伤的那次完全是一样的事件。
Come on, you think, really, 95% after that?
算了吧，真的，经过那次之后你还觉得是95%？
I'm just thinking that, you know, we just have to have a lot of faith in things to work out. So I forgive him, you know? I just shouldn't have been that close.
我只是在想，你知道，我们必须对事情的发展充满信心。所以我原谅它，你知道吗？我只是不该离得那么近。
Yeah. What would Second Chance have to do to convince you he's never going to be like Chance? Like, how many times would he have to attack you?
是的。“第二次机会”必须做些什么才能让你确信它永远不会像“机会”？比如说，它必须攻击你多少次？
After he's seven, then he has to attack me. Then the lines will be drawn in the sand, like we were discussing.
等它七岁之后，它要是再攻击我，那底线就画好了，就像我们讨论的那样。
Yeah. You still have hope.
是的。你仍然抱有希望。
Oh, yeah. Surely, yeah. I've been having fun here, and-- Sandra, hand me that horse, would you?
哦，当然，是的。我在这里玩得很开心，而且……桑德拉，把那匹马递给我，好吗？
Sandra hands him this little toy horse that one of their friends brought Ralph.
桑德拉递给他那个朋友带给拉尔夫的小玩具马。
How does it work?
它是怎么用的？
[GALLOPING SOUND]
[奔跑声]
[NEIGHING]
[嘶鸣声]
[RALPH LAUGHS]
[拉尔夫大笑]
[GALLOPING SOUND]
[奔跑声]
[NEIGHING]
[嘶鸣声]
That's how I feel right now, you know? He-he-he-he-he-he-he. I'm going to walk out of here tomorrow or the next day, and I'll go right back out there and give him another bucket of feed. I mean, that's what you have to do.
我现在感觉就是这样，你知道吗？哈哈哈哈。我明天或后天就会走出这里，我会直接回到那里给它再喂一桶饲料。我是说，你必须这么做。
Yeah.
是的。
If it was easy, there'd be a bunch of kids out there taking care of Brahman bulls.
如果这很容易，就会有很多孩子在照顾婆罗门公牛了。
Well, that happened back in 2005, which was when this episode was first broadcast. Ralph turned out to be right. As Second Chance got older, he did become tamer and more trustworthy, but never as docile as Chance was. Sandra and Ralph always had to be careful with him. And in March of 2008, eight years old, Second Chance died.
嗯，那是2005年发生的，那是这集节目首次播出的时候。拉尔夫确实是对的。随着“第二次机会”长大，它确实变得更温顺、更可靠了，但从来没有像“机会”那么驯服。桑德拉和拉尔夫一直不得不对它保持小心。2008年3月，“第二次机会”去世了，享年八岁。
In an email to friends, Sandra wrote, "To think that this huge animal who's put Ralph in the hospital twice will be so missed-- it never occurred to us that by having a clone we would lose him twice." Sandra said that before his death, Texas A&M collected some tissue, which opened the door for a possibility of a Third Chance.
在一封给朋友的邮件中，桑德拉写道：“想到这头巨大的动物曾两次把拉尔夫送进医院，却还是这么让人怀念——我们从未想到，通过克隆，我们竟然会失去它两次。”桑德拉说，在它去世前，德州农工大学采集了一些组织，这打开了第三次机会的可能性。
This story, by the way, is one that we did for our TV show back when we had a series on Showtime. If you're curious to see Chance, and Second Chance, and Ralph, and Sandra, you can find the series at Showtime, or Amazon Prime, or iTunes.
顺便说一句，这个故事是我们以前在Showtime系列节目时制作的。如果你好奇想看看“机会”、“第二次机会”、拉尔夫和桑德拉，你可以在Showtime、亚马逊Prime或iTunes上找到这个系列。
Act Three, "French Kiss." We end our program today with this story from Sara Vowell of a man reunited with a country. People lined the roads to see him wherever he traveled. Newspaper accounts called it "a delirium of feeling." Here's Sarah.
第三幕，“法式热吻”。今天我们以莎拉·沃威尔讲述的一个男人与国家重聚的故事结束我们的节目。人们排在道路两旁看他旅行经过。报纸报道称这是一种“情感的狂热”。这是莎拉的报道。
On August 16, 1824, an elderly French gentleman sailed into New York Harbor, and giddy Americans were there to welcome him-- or rather, to welcome him back. It had been 30 years since the Revolutionary War hero, the Marquis de Lafayette, had last set foot in the United States. And he was so beloved, so universally revered, that the frenzy, the ardor of his reception has yet to be matched. 80,000 people showed up to cheer for Lafayette-- 80,000. The entire population of New York at the time was 120,000.
1824年8月16日，一位年长的法国绅士航行进入纽约港，兴奋的美国人在那里欢迎他——或者说，欢迎他归来。距离独立战争英雄、拉法耶特侯爵上次踏上美国土地已经30年了。他是如此受爱戴，如此普遍受尊敬，以至于他接待时的那种狂热和激情至今无人能比。8万民众现身为拉法耶特欢呼——8万。纽约当时的总人口也才12万。
When Lafayette first got here in 1777, he was only 19 years old. A wealthy, orphaned aristocrat, he charmed his way into a commission in George Washington's Continental Army as an unpaid volunteer. He was a relentless soldier, almost freakishly brave, disciplined and oozing panache all at once.
拉法耶特1777年第一次来到这里时，年仅19岁。作为一位富有的孤儿贵族，他通过魅力获得乔治·华盛顿大陆军的军衔，担任无薪志愿者。他是一位无情的士兵，几乎勇敢得不可思议，纪律严明，同时又风度翩翩。
He rode a white horse, was wounded in the Battle of Brandywine, led the liberation of Virginia, and suffered through a winter at Valley Forge, living among his fellow soldiers in a crummy hut, though he could have easily afforded to wait for spring in a mansion the size of Newark. His troops adored him. George Washington considered him his adopted son. Alexander Hamilton wrote him letters that read like mash notes.
他骑着白马，在布兰迪万战役中受伤，领导了解放弗吉尼亚的行动，并在福吉谷的冬天忍受了磨难，和战友们住在一起，尽管他完全负担得起在像纽瓦克那么大的豪宅里等待春天。他的军队崇拜他。乔治·华盛顿视他为养子。亚历山大·汉密尔顿写给他的信读起来就像情书。
Invited by his old friend, President Monroe, to be the nation's guest on the eve of the 50th anniversary of American independence, Lafayette's trip here amounted to a euphoric 13-month victory lap around the country in which he visited all of the then-24 states. Everywhere Lafayette went, he was serenaded by music composed in his honor-- "Hail Lafayette," "Lafayette's March," "The Lafayette Waltz," "The Lafayette Rondo," and in decreasing geographical order, the songs, "Lafayette's Welcome to North America," "Lafayette's Welcome to the United States," "Lafayette's Welcome to New York," and "Lafayette's Welcome to Philadelphia."
受老友门罗总统的邀请，在美国独立50周年前夕作为国家的客人，拉法耶特的此次行程相当于一场长达13个月、令人陶醉的环国胜利巡回赛，他访问了当时所有的24个州。无论拉法耶特走到哪里，他都会听到为纪念他而创作的音乐——《拉法耶特万岁》、《拉法耶特进行曲》、《拉法耶特圆舞曲》、《拉法耶特回旋曲》，按地理顺序依次有歌曲《拉法耶特欢迎来到北美》、《拉法耶特欢迎来到美国》、《拉法耶特欢迎来到纽约》和《拉法耶特欢迎来到费城》。
Meanwhile, the souvenir trade cranked out an unprecedented pile of Lafayette-themed knickknacks from ladies' gloves to dishes. How many times must he have reached for a cookie and seen his own eyes staring back at him from a commemorative plate?
与此同时，纪念品贸易推出了前所未有的以拉法耶特为主题的小饰品，从女士手套到餐具。他到底有多少次伸手去拿饼干，看到自己的眼睛在纪念盘上盯着自己？
In Brooklyn, Lafayette was invited to lay the cornerstone of a new Children's Library. At the ceremony, he picked up and kissed a neighborhood kid, the five-year-old Walt Whitman. In Philadelphia, the French chef in charge of preparing the-- count 'em-- 60 courses for Lafayette's banquet dropped dead in his kitchen that very morning, felled by overwork and the steam heat of simmering sauces.
在布鲁克林，拉法耶特被邀请为一座新的儿童图书馆奠基。在仪式上，他抱起并亲吻了一名邻家小孩，也就是五岁的沃尔特·惠特曼。在费城，负责准备——数数吧——60道菜的宴会的法国厨师，就在当天早上在厨房里猝死了，倒在过劳和酱汁炖煮的热气下。
And speaking of Philadelphia, if you have visited what came to be called Independence Hall, you have Lafayette to thank. The building where the Declaration of Independence and the Constitution were signed was decrepit and abandoned. It was only when Philadelphians needed a symbolically appropriate place for Lafayette's reception did they remember the old hall and sweep up.
说到费城，如果你访问过所谓的“独立厅”，你得感谢拉法耶特。那个签署《独立宣言》和《宪法》的建筑曾破败不堪、无人问津。只有当费城人需要一个象征性合适的地方来接待拉法耶特时，他们才想起旧厅并打扫干净。
When Lafayette waded through the crowd of 20,000 locals there to greet him and crossed the-- to him-- hallowed threshold, he preached, "Within these sacred walls, by a council of wise and devoted patriots, was boldly declared the independence of these vast United States, which has begun for the civilized world the era of a new and of the only true social order founded on the inalienable rights of man." Notice the melancholy in that word, "only", when he hails American government as the "only" true social order founded on the inalienable rights of man.
当拉法耶特穿过2万当地人迎接他的队伍，跨过对他来说神圣的门槛时，他感叹道：“在这神圣的墙内，由一群英明、忠诚的爱国者组成的议会，大胆宣布了这些庞大的合众国的独立，这为文明世界开启了一个新的，也是唯一真正的社会秩序时代，建立在人不可剥夺的权利之上。”注意到他在称赞美国政府是建立在人不可剥夺权利之上的“唯一”真正社会秩序时，话语中流露出的忧郁了吗？
After the French Revolution of 1789, Lafayette not only watched his hopes for American-style civil liberties in his homeland get chopped into thousands of guillotined pieces during the Reign of Terror, he subsequently spent five years in a royal Austrian prison and lived through the restoration of the French king, the dictatorship of Napoleon, and the restoration of yet another French king. So Lafayette, more than anyone, was aware of the uniqueness and the importance of the American republic.
1789年法国大革命后，拉法耶特不仅目睹了他在祖国实现美国式公民自由的希望在恐怖统治期间被送上断头台，切成碎片，他还先后在奥地利皇家监狱度过了五年，历经了法国国王复辟、拿破仑独裁，以及另一个法国国王的复辟。所以，拉法耶特比任何人都了解美国共和国的独特性和重要性。
At that point, American democracy had descended from its early idealism into the kind of messy partisan backbiting we're familiar with today. Lafayette's arrival in 1824 coincides with one of the most contentious presidential elections in American history, with no clear electoral college winner between John Quincy Adams and Andrew Jackson, with Adams assuming the presidency under suspicions some labeled "the corrupt bargain."
在那时，美国民主已经从早期的理想主义跌落到我们今天熟悉的混乱的党派抨击中。拉法耶特1824年的到来恰逢美国历史上最激烈的总统选举之一，约翰·昆西·亚当斯和安德鲁·杰克逊之间没有明确的选举团获胜者，亚当斯在“腐败交易”的怀疑中出任总统。
Meanwhile, Congress had just fought its first epic battle over slavery, the fight that led to the Missouri Compromise, the fight that would soon enough lead to the Civil War. But Lafayette, belonging to neither North nor South, to no political party or faction, was a walking, talking reminder of the sacrifices and bravery of the revolutionary generation and what they wanted this country to be. His return was not just a reunion with his beloved Americans, it was a reunion for Americans with their own astonishing, singular past.
与此同时，国会刚刚进行了第一次关于奴隶制的史诗级斗争，这场斗争导致了《密苏里妥协》，这场斗争很快就会导致内战。但拉法耶特不属于北方也不属于南方，不属于任何政党或派系，他是一个行走的、谈话的提醒者，提醒人们革命一代的牺牲和勇敢，以及他们想要这个国家变成什么样。他的回归不仅仅是与他所爱的美国人重聚，更是美国人与他们自己令人惊叹、独特的过去的一次重聚。
On New Year's Day, 1825, Congress threw him yet another of his nightly banquets. And Speaker of the House, Henry Clay, toasted Lafayette as a great apostle of Liberty. In reply, Lafayette toasted back with a prophecy-- "To the perpetual union of the United States. It has always served us in times of storm. One day, it will save the world."
1825年元旦，国会再次为他举办了晚宴。众议院议长亨利·克莱将拉法耶特敬酒为伟大的自由使徒。拉法耶特以预言回敬——“为了合众国的永久统一。它总是在暴风雨时刻服务于我们。有一天，它将拯救世界。”
And he was right. Every so often, America has saved the world. Of course, we muck it up every now and then, as well. But in 1917, after American Expeditionary Forces crossed the Atlantic to aid France in World War I, General Pershing marched his troops to Lafayette's Paris grave where the old soldier had been buried under dirt from Bunker Hill. They placed an American flag into that American dirt. Lafayette, one of them said, we are here.
他是对的。每隔一段时间，美国确实拯救了世界。当然，我们也时不时搞砸，正如偶尔所见。但在1917年，美国远征军横跨大西洋支援法国一战后，潘兴将军带领军队行进到拉法耶特位于巴黎的坟墓，这位老兵被埋葬在来自邦克山土壤之下。他们将一面美国国旗插入那片美国土壤中。其中一人说，拉法耶特，我们到了。
Sarah Vowell. Her book about Lafayette's experiences in America is called, Lafayette in the Somewhat United States.
莎拉·沃威尔。她关于拉法耶特在美国经历的书名为《有点联合的美国里的拉法耶特》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - MASE, "WELCOME BACK"]
[音乐播放 - Mase，《欢迎回来》]
(SINGING) Welcome back.
(演唱) 欢迎回来。
Oh, hey, man, how you doin'? You good? I know you like that.
哦，嘿，伙计，你怎么样？还好吗？我知道你喜欢那个。
(SINGING) Welcome back.
(演唱) 欢迎回来。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Diane Cook, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollock Our senior producer for today's show was Julie Snyder. Additional production on today's rerun from Jessica Lussenhop, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Special thanks today to Chandra Conway for bringing us this story of Second Chance, also to Chris Wilcha and Jenny Golden.
今天我们的节目由亚历克斯·布伦伯格和我本人制作，黛安·库克、简·玛丽、莎拉·科尼格和丽莎·波洛克参与。今天节目的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。今天重播的额外制作由杰西卡·卢森霍普、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼完成。今天特别感谢钱德拉·康威为我们带来这个“第二次机会”的故事，也感谢克里斯·威尔查和珍妮·戈尔登。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who waved around a big knife and told me my very first day on the job--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他在我上班的第一天就挥舞着一把大刀告诉我——
And you watch this, because I'm only gonna show you once.
现在你看好，因为我只给你演示一次。
Oh, no!
哦，不！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周会有更多《美国生活》的故事。